foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's webinar a
laboratory and clinical
multi-disciplinary partnership for the
treatment of cancer patients I am
antonina Salcido of lab roots and I will
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labroots and brought to you
by T2 biosystems to learn more please
visit t2biosystems.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click Send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
I'd like to now welcome our speakers
doctors Dr James Snyder director of
microbiology and infectious diseases
molecular diagnostics at the University
of Louisville Hospital and Dr Robert
Emmons head of the blood cancer
transplant and cellular therapy division
at University of Louisville health
Dr Snyder welcome you may now begin your
presentation
well thank you very much and would like
to thank T2 biosystem for sponsoring
this continuing education opportunity
and we're going to be talking to you
about our experience with the
implementation of the t2 biosystems and
we also start off with our disclosures
my way of objectives we want to discuss
the goals for adding the t2 system to
our service
the importance of Partnerships which I
will reiterate as we are going through
this we couldn't do it without a
partnership I can tell you that right
off the beginning
we'll mention a little bit about
managing of results in terms of
releasing them
um I'll finish with a brief case study
Dr Emmons will have several other cases
that he's going to present from the
physician's perspective
and then kind of give a summary as to
what we consider or have been best
practices for our Partnerships
in addition to our collaboration when
trying to implement a new technology
this as most of you know is a photo of
the t2 bias systems consists of two
panels a bacterial panel and a Canada
panel and as you can see under the
bacterial panel these are essentially
the what we call the Escape
organisms of which there are five and
then for the Canada panel listed as
indicated there
once again it's a very sensitive system
and uh I'm going to share with you some
of the data that we pulled
to give you some indication of our
experiences uh for the for the this year
to to date so to speak
um well once again
we are in an era of Rapid Diagnostics
and Rapid Diagnostics is what is driving
our future planning and I first became
aware of the t2 biosystem about six
years ago
and at that time we were under
management by a private Health Care
Organization
and I was called by the Vice President
of Operations of this management company
and he said
are you familiar with the t2 biosystems
technology and I said well I've heard of
it I've not really had my hands on it
and Etc he says well he said I would
recommend you consider looking at it
because it's going to replace blood
cultures
and my eyes went up and I said replace
blood cultures well yeah this is a
direct system you won't need to do blood
cultures anymore
and I said well I find that very hard to
believe and I doubt whether it's
designed to replace our blood cultures
but at that time we were in we had
adopted the policy or the philosophy of
Rapid Diagnostics as many of you know
the Technologies are there they're
continuing to be available and I believe
that we need to be pursuing
state-of-the-art technology Diagnostics
when feasible and practical
so why rapid Diagnostics why why is this
driving us
Well we'd like to get an accurate but a
diag early laboratory diagnosis as soon
as possible
in other words culture independent
Diagnostics or direct specimen testing
and as you know we will know the t2
biosystem is a direct specimen testing
yes culture is still the gold standard
but culture is has low sensitivity
obviously increased turnaround time
and sometimes or frequently we fail to
identify the ideological agent with many
of our methods but I think the multitask
has has really been the uh
source of improved identification with
its uh trevetous database in both the
bacterial the fungal as well as the
mycobacterial data set
we think that rapid Diagnostics is very
critical to influence or initiate
therapy and specifically targeted
therapy
with ultimately the goal to reduce
morbidity and mortality
and one of the features that I think is
a benefit of a direct technology such as
this is this supports random microbial
stewardship
but the goal being to go from interior
therapy to neural Spectrum therapy uh
including targeted therapy and sometimes
decisions have to be made regarding do
we escalate do we de-escalate or can we
terminate so it depends on the situation
obviously to influence the unnecessary
use of antimicrobials and this is what's
gotten us into trouble in the last
several years with the resistance
problems that we're contending with
along with the increased health care
costs
we also think that rapid Diagnostics
will reduce poor outcomes in patients
that have either acute bacterial
infections or a fungal infection and
specifically the examples there are
sepsis and in addition to bacteremia and
fungamia and we hope to impact on the
reduction of length of stay
and or readmission rates which we
defined as they are readmitted for the
same reason of their initial
admission so once again we think that
the laboratory can play a key role in
all these factors but that is what's
driving our thinking in terms of Rapid
Diagnostics
so our goals for adding this system to
our test menu was how do we gain support
where do we need to start and so forth
keep in mind we're back six years and
during that period of time the
Hospital management if you will
specifically led by the medical staff
terminated the relationship with the
private managing company
and as a result of that became
independent as since then grown to eight
hospitals and four small medical centers
um
so after we became aware of the
technology and the new Administration
came in I thought uh oh we're back to
square one we're going to have to start
over again
and as a result of that uh we uh decided
to develop a strategy
to gain support for acquiring the
technology well the first thing that we
did was to do an in-house performance
evaluation
with companies support of course
and in addition to that uh perform a
cost analysis determine our direct cost
for generating a reportable and at the
same time uh work with management to
determine our operational costs to the
point that we knew what exactly it cost
us to generate a result
our other Foundation was on the selling
point was it would support the sepsis
program which became very uh focused
about four years ago
and uh we thought you know with this
system we couldn't directly support the
sepsis program
we could also support the antimicrobial
stewardship program uh
once again another benefit of this
technology
we introduced about three and a half
years ago diagnostic stewardship
Committee in other words we needed to
decide through diagnostic stewardship
if the assay should be available as an
open assay where anybody can order it or
should it be restricted to certain
services
so that led up to a pilot study in
addition to our concern about his
performance its accuracy and comparison
to the gold standard of course culture
we wanted to do another pilot study
which we partnered with Pharmacy to
determine what if any impact on patient
management
and outcomes on patient management and
so forth including link to stay now we
know in the transplant program that
length of stay is not going to be
impacted because of the severity and the
complexity of those patients disease
process
another question we had to answer was
these rapid Technologies are designed to
grow 24 7.
we needed a 24 7 staff to make this
available around the clock
and so we went to Administration
and since we became a core laboratory
for the other institutions including
University Hospital we were able to
convince them that if we were going to
be efficient and maintain a high level
productivity we needed to be generating
results 24 7 thus requiring a dedicated
and I emphasize dedicated 24 7
microbiology staff and we were fortunate
to get that support
and then covert hit and covered as for
many of you or if not all of you
completely disrupted our operation in
that we had to diverse several of our
staff technologists to covet testing 24
7 around the clock so our 24 7
generation of other results except for
those immediate stat results and this
includes T2
uh uh really were not affected there may
have been some delays but once again we
were able to uh
maintain the course and provide the uh
the Physicians with their results while
we were doing covet it seemed like we
were doing covert all the time anyway
that's another story and we also had to
examine the impact on workflow so all
those factors were taken into
consideration in terms of here are our
goals now we need to accomplish those
goals
so it was a multi-disciplinary process
to gain approval as I mentioned the
laboratory cost analysis uh the direct
cost specifically and the potential
savings to the institution
in antimicrobials length of stay and so
forth and that's a hard concept to sell
to administrators
potential savings to the institution
they're beginning to ask what are we
getting out of our investment uh in in
whatever the technology is we're
currently doing or are creating a study
to to try to answer that question in
more detail for the t2
um
our test verification data following our
performance analysis that was submitted
to management
and uh I learned one thing that many of
you already know they really don't care
about the science what is it going to
cost me what is the return on my
investment
we also provided representative
literature uh
we informed them that the impact it
would have on workflow and this was
during the coveted outbreak in our
diversion to 24 7 testing but we had a
pretty good idea of how it would impact
on workflow and Staffing was
able to accommodate testing as necessary
so we put together a formal
justification
and sent the request to lab management
who in turn took it to the upper
Administration
and we also had with that letters of
support from the pharmacy and other
Support Services the example was the
bone marrow transplant Service as well
as our infectious disease colleagues and
you will hear me say later well in the
last bullet there Dr Emmons and his
colleagues at the Cancer Center were
really the key that
drove the approval of putting the system
online as a new service
so as that one bullet indicates that
sometime thereafter the c-suite as I
call them approve the acquisition and so
we fully activated the instrument and
we're providing testing for both Canada
panels and the bacterial panels
um that also led to a question uh
regarding this multi-disciplinary
process of how to implement it so prior
to implementation and this is very
important we scheduled training of the
phlebotomist our preference was that
phlebotomists would draw altitudes along
with an accompanied blood culture but in
some areas nursing Personnel were also
trained uh for for one purpose of
uniformity and Sample collection we all
do it the same way
um
we selected and trained a technical
staff on the operational system it is in
our molecular Diagnostics lab where we
have four technologists that are highly
trained and molecular Diagnostics
including the t2 system
we also created an electronic order set
in our Cerner system
and I'll mention a little more about how
we release results and so forth but the
first key thing and usually a hold up in
many Laboratories is is the I.T portion
of it it took uh probably three months
to get an order set built to to order T2
so when we identified to go live date
and we uh communicated that day to all
the services that were eligible to order
the test
and currently we call positive results
to the respective units that are
ordering the test obviously we entered
the results in the laboratory reporting
system and at the same time
we are starting to negotiate with the
pharmacy to call all positive results to
Pharmacy which would include uh
are other Multiplex pcrs because
Pharmacy is in a better position to act
on it immediately
and Dr Evans may have more comments on
on getting results and so forth but the
emphasis that we've really had to place
and we still have to place it today
because as you know in in Laboratories
and nursing there's a relatively High
turnover
and so it's a constant training or
reinforcement and we put emphasis on the
importance
of collecting the t2 sample
along with a peripheral blood culture
and you'll hear me mention later that
there are no line draws eligible to be
tested by the t2 system so they must
acquire the t2 the 4ml 3 to 4 ml sample
and then bring that to the laboratory
with a blood culture sometimes there's
the delay in getting a blood culture and
we give them
an hour to get the peripheral blood
culture any blood culture comes in at
Beyond an hour we do not do the t2 on
because of the sensitivity of the test
and Etc
so it is a multi-disciplinary process
ordering criteria this gets back to what
I said earlier with regards to who can
order it we decided that we would
restrict The Ordering of the t2 testing
to high-risk patients we went back and
looked at epidemiology and we found that
in our transplant group
we've had the highest rates of fungibia
and in the non-transplant groups it was
bacterial so that led us to make a
recommendation this is not a rule or a
restriction it's a recommendation
intensive care patients we recommend
that they order a T2 bacterial panel in
the transplant programs we recommend
they order the Canada panel
in oncology we also recommend ordering
the Canada panel the emergency room uh
recommended the the t2 bacteria panel be
ordered and infectious disease can
either order Canada or bacterial
now I want to remind you that they can
order both panels at one time but keep
in mind that requires two three to four
ml blood specimens
probably the biggest challenge was the
training of phlebotomists because
there's a high turnover rate in
phlebotomy as well as nursing personnel
and once again
emphasize if this is going to be done
properly you must collect the t2
and it must be accompanied by a
peripheral blood culture that is very
critical
here is some data that we pulled
together from January to June of this
year I also sprinkled in some data from
the past few weeks kind of looking at
our test volume and our comparison to
culture
I think this has some interesting
information uh we did a total of 562
tests and I will say that the majority
of those tests were bacterial in nature
less so with the fungal panels so the
bacterial panels uh were in predominance
so I broke it down between the areas you
see here the t2 positive versus culture
negative the t2 negative the culture
positive and T2 positive culture
positive and then the occursive
invalidance
now the t2 positive and culture is
negatives you can see there were 12
positive candidate results and 40
bacteria once again the bacterial panels
were
at the highest level
um
somebody would question what is the t2
positive in a culture negative those are
good questions and I think I don't
really have a specific answer but one
question I have asked is could this
represent
a transient back to Remia or candemia
and the bacterial or fungal load in the
actual blood specimen was so low and we
know that the blood culture sensitivity
is around 60 to 70 percent so that may
account for the positive Target versus a
negative culture
so we know as I said that blood cultures
lack sensitivity
and this could also be a result of a low
volume of blood we require 20 miles per
draw 10 mL is divided between an aerobic
and anaerobic bottle if they want a
fungus blood culture we substitute the
anaerobic bottle with the fungal bottle
but it's 10 ml per bottle or 8 to 10 MLS
per bottle
we also know once again that the t2s
technology has a higher sensitivity than
culture so that T2
positivity uh could mean several things
and I'll the case I'll end with is the
perfect example that which I'll show you
in a few minutes T2 negative culture
positive we had one T2 Canada positive
and that happened to be dubalensis and
that organism is not on the target list
currently for the the system
uh 28 bacterial pauses and it's
interesting when I went back to look at
those the majority of those bacteria
that were recovered in culture and not
detected by T2 were organisms that are
not on the bacterial panel or were none
of the Escape organisms if you will for
example Club cell orogenes streptococcus
pneumonia cryptococcus neoformons
anaerobes
uh the anthropacticloitly complex
and then if we move over to the t2
positive culture positive
uh I think it pretty much speak for
herself but we did notice on two
occasions we had a co-infection one of
which involved Canada perhapsulosis and
pseudomonas of Virgin Osa in that
particular case only the pseudomonas of
originosa was detected by the t2
and then the E coli seratio co-infection
with the E coli being detected we have
run into some where the culture was
positive and the t2 was negative and
these were organisms that for some
unknown reason were not detected by the
t2
um
if you look at the invalids
respectively for the candidate in the
bacterial panel uh when you get an
invalid that indicates that the internal
control was not detected
and the sources of these invalids we
know are in part we have more questions
on this but in part due to known
interfering substances
that can interfere with the detection of
the internal control
or for example of potassium EDTA
interrelipids that are in concentrations
are greater than or 160 milligrams per
deciliter in the situations of lipemia
tpn and lipid Emulsion and also contrast
that is used in MRI can interfere and
give you an invalid result some other
questions we've identified
that need to be answered are what impact
do combination antibiotics have on
generating imbalance we know that single
antibiotic that has no impact but what
about two maybe three antibiotics what
about
the chemotherapy agents that are used
that has never been answered and needs
to be studied and hopefully we can be a
part of that but I thought it was very
interesting and I tracked this every day
and once again as I said this data
represents primarily from January
through June but at the same time I
sprinkled in a few from the last couple
of weeks
so I mentioned some of these reasons for
non-concordance between the t2 and the
culture
one again organisms not in the t2 beta
bit both bacteria and fungi they're
going to probably expand the database
and I just learned last week that
they're going to be adding acinetobacter
I mentioned the interfering substances
and we also have a leading problem in
our lab which we are working diligently
to correct
we get a significant number here lately
for sure of q and s quantity not
sufficient in other words that T2
samples less than three MLS remember I
said it has to be between three and four
MLS
uh sometimes we will get a one hour
delay of the peripheral blood sample
after the t2 has been cultured
uh that that relates to non-concorders
uh we have found on some occasions not a
lot that they're sending blood for T2
testing that's been drawn from the line
and once again that's part of the
continuing education to remind them that
line draws are not eligible
and then of course staff turnover is
always a problem because it disrupts
consistency and uniformity this occurs
both on the nursing as well as the
quality team so we are really trained
train train on a regular basis because
of that staff turnover so it is a
problem it's something to be aware of
when instituting this technology or any
other technology
this is a one case I want to share with
you this was early in the go live or
during the pilot study where we had an
oncology patient that had persistent
spiking fevers they received broad
spectrum antibiotics they had a port in
place all blood cultures were negative
but fevers continued to occur
and the plan was to remove the port and
hope that the offending organism had
been treated a T2 was done and it was
positive for the at that time the
combination of albicans of tropicalis
turned out to be Canada tropicalis the
port was removed after we had that T2
positivity
the antibiotics were discontinued
and uh because the patient was placed on
targeted antifungal therapy uh the fever
subsided and the patient was uh
eventually discharged which I thought
was a good story in that the t2 had an
impact on patient management and had a
good outcome and as I said Dr Emmons
will have some additional cases to
present to you
so in summary we felt without question
in our evaluation that it met the
criteria performance we were able to
make it available 24 7. it's been
endorsed by the key providers Niantic by
or emphasize once again Dr Emmons and
the group at the Cancer Center were
really supportive and the convinced
Administration we needed to have this
uh the impact study is ongoing uh we're
partnering with Pharmacy to look at that
particular area with emphasis on Patient
Care Management and antimicrobial use so
it's a partnership
a partnership with the pharmacy in
addition to the micro lab the providers
very very important I cannot over
emphasize uh the the importance of a
partnership if you can get their support
it makes it much simpler if you will or
eases the pain in going to
Administration and asking for the
acquisition of Technology this type so
it is definitely a team effort one
person themselves cannot do it alone and
currently the t2 biosis is what I call
the only game in town I think it's
serving its purposes uh you know like
any instrumentation you're going to have
periodic maintenance issues but I have
to say the company has been extremely
responsive and supportive and our
downtime has been very very minimal so
with that I will conclude by
acknowledging one of our first year
pathology residents Dr Randa Oben who
pulled together all this data and she
worked on it for about two weeks once
she understood the pattern and so forth
she did an outstanding job and I wanted
to acknowledge her so at this time I'm
going to thank you and I'm going to turn
it over to Dr Emmons
so many thanks to uh our partner in the
Infectious Disease and microbiology
World James Snyder who brought this to
our attention and my purpose in my talk
today is to give you a little background
in terms of the way we think about
infectious disease and the evolution of
our thinking that has affected what we
care about in terms of uh detecting
organisms going forward and the vital
need to detect early to tailor therapy
and alter outcomes which have become
increasingly dependent on our
understanding of the changes that happen
within patients in their microbiome and
the relative risk of various organisms
at various time points after their
various therapies so thanks to both T2
biosystems and lab roots for inviting me
and including me in this presentation
and I don't have any disclosures that
are pertinent to this talk today
so our patients are of course
immunocompromised they are
immunocompromised in a number of
different ways they are certainly often
immunocompromised because of low
leukocyte counts and that includes
neutropenia most notably early after
many rounds of therapy but also in our
transplant patients especially prolonged
periods of lymphopenia and therefore the
types of organisms that we're most
interested in detecting vary according
to the phase of therapy that the patient
is in this graph that you're seeing in
front of you is sort of a general graph
of how engraftment occurs after
transplant the difference between this
and patients undergoing for example
induction therapy for AML or cycles of
chemotherapy for lymphoma are that the
relative depth and Recovery times for B
cells and CD4 T cells and plasma cells
are in general shorter but they can also
be very profoundly affected as
especially in the Modern Age of therapy
and as many of you know we're moving
into the cellular therapy age which
causes even more profound depletion
oftentimes of these other cellular
populations Beyond neutrophils that have
profound impacts on the relative
likelihood of infection and also changes
in the patient's response to
immunotherapy
in general there are three phases of
risk that we talk about for our
immunocompromised hosts in the heme
malignancy world the pre-enraftment the
post engraftment the late phase the
pre-enraftment phase is predominantly
the phase in which we are currently
using the t2 systems and that's why I
really want to focus on that and this is
the period at which patients have had
often high-dose chemotherapy or
immunotherapy in such a way that their
neutrophils and their cellular immune
systems are quite compromised and they
are therefore predisposed to a variety
of different bacterial infections they
are also often mucosally impaired in the
mouth and through the entire Elementary
tract which makes it easier for the
organisms to get into the bloodstream
hence early detection of these very high
risk infections in this high-risk
population becomes vital
and as another side as we'll talk about
in a few later slides we don't want to
overdo the suppression of both organisms
and immune systems in these patients so
less is better as we have learned
evolutionarily over time
as you can see it's not just bacteria
although bacteria and fungus are of
course the major discussions in our
discussion of the t2 system today but
there are certainly viruses and other
arms of the bacterial
microbiome that affect the course of
transplant and immune recovery including
archaea now that are emerging that we'll
talk about briefly at the end of the
talk if you'd like
given this the management of the
patients involves considerations of
primary prevention that is things like
immunization and prophylaxis with
various bacterial antibacterials or
antifungals
secondary prevention which the t2 system
is of course a vital potential member of
because of the early detection and
treatment of often very serious
infections bacterial and fungal most
notably but there are certainly
respiratory viruses other viruses and
mold that we are often very worried
about in these neutropenic patients who
are often immunocompromised not just
from their immediate therapy but their
many rounds of previous therapy and
finally tertiary prevention the
management of conditions that predispose
patients is another thing to touch on
and I'll talk about that in the context
of the microbiome to come
in the long term we have noted and these
are things that have Arisen over the
last 50 years of understanding and
immunocompromised patients and
Transplant that unfortunately relapse an
infection play the greatest roles in the
mortality risk for our patients still
and so certainly the early detection and
treatment of these very serious
infections is a critical part of the
overall outcome but even beyond the
understanding of infectious risk our
understanding of how the microbiome and
how infections impact on the Advent of
graft versus host disease and aloe
transplant in CMV reactivation and
secondary complications from that virus
because of other infections or the
impact of things like radiation and
high-dose chemotherapy are often caught
up very much in the context of what the
patients get infected with and how that
affects their all course
hence there was a theory going back now
50 years that the ideal situation for
transplant and immunocompromised
patients was to eliminate all microbiome
and microorganisms from the alimentary
tract to quote protect them from the
potential of those bugs getting into the
blood and so in the early days drugs
like neomycin and other very Draconian
antibacterials were used from Mouse
studies that seemed to show that the
elimination of microorganisms helped to
lower relative morbidity and mortality
and this was at a time of course when
patients were also getting very
Draconian doses of both chemotherapy and
radiation which caused major damage to
the GI tract in much higher rates of
passage of microorganisms across into
the bloodstream
since those regimens have given way to
much less Draconian regimens over time
there then became still an understanding
of the need to have some protection for
patients with primary prophylaxis but
the primary prophylaxis has been
gradually decreasing over time such that
we went from drugs like neomycin to
other drugs and then there were large
both prospective and retrospective
studies to show that drugs like for
example bactrim was compared directly to
the floxins to look at relative
morbidity and mortality both in the
setting of standard chemotherapy and
Transplant which seemed to show that
there was greater survival and lesser
failure with quinolones versus drugs
like trimethoprim sulfamethoxazide or
bactrim and so the types of
antibacterials that were used over time
have changed and have emphasized less
suppression especially of anaerobes and
often certain gram negatives as well
what about gram-positive organisms in
general there's been no evidence that
prophylaxis against gram-positive
organisms in blood transplant in blood
cancer or transplant has been necessary
however there are now emerging data
about the importance of VRE in aloe
transplant and immunomodulation is part
of the crosstalk that occurs within the
alimentary tract between the immune
system and microorganisms over time
so we've known for a while that Dre
colonization and aloe transplant
patients actually affects day 100
survival
and there was a lot of confusion about
this because it didn't seem to be
directly related to the actual infection
with VRE and from that then came the
realization early on and this is going
back 15 years or so that the organisms
that line the elementary tract have an
interplay with both the elementary cells
as well as the immune system cells in
setting up a crosstalk that helps to
prevent the overgrowth of certain very
pathogenic organisms over time
hence in this plus pathogens paper which
is a review article about how the risk
of enterococcal bloodstream infections
and the risk of candidal infections
increases as one eliminates certain key
members of anaerobic commensural
bacteria in the alimentary tract because
specifically of crosstalk and trophic
mechanisms that occur in the epithelial
cells of the GI tract we gained an
understanding of how we can do damage to
patients by overdoing antibacterial
prophylaxis so we've pulled way back in
our prophylaxis in the Modern Age
so our understanding now of the need to
take a careful appraisal of the
bacterial complement of the GI tract for
both the immediate prevention of
overgrowth of resistant organisms the
lowering of bloodstream infections and
now the Advent of improved immunotherapy
has led to protocols in which we are
trying to emphasize the gut microbiota
and we are doing this now through
narrowing the targeting of antibiotics
and avoiding as much as possible the
addition of other antibiotics especially
early in the course which is of course
why systems like T2 are so important to
help us both avoid too much primary
prophylaxis and two early edition of
secondary treatment into the course of
these patients Therapies
invasive mold is still a major issue for
us as well and I know certainly candida
is what the t2 systems are currently
testing for but I want to emphasize that
for many of our patients not just
candidate but invasive mold becomes a
critical issue to detect early as well
this is something for futures
discussions but I want to make clear to
everybody what a major issue that
Edition
about that
um uh and this is to show that during
periods of neutropenia especially those
that go on for longer than 20 days the
risk of invasive mold infections goes
way up so we want to do a better job
detecting certainly early candidemia but
also invasive molds we also realize that
just like for antibacterials the early
inclusion of antifungals can also have
profound effects on the microbiome as
well
and just to emphasize for everybody the
microbiome is uh this uh complement of
bacteria that grow within each of our
systems all of our non-sterile body
surfaces especially our elementary tract
are characterized by specific organisms
in fact humans have about 23 000 genes
but our combined microbiome has about 33
000 genes uh and 33 000
um uh so 3.3 million is what I should
say genes some bacterial genes only
benefit the host but some are mixed like
those that give us for example the
ability to make vitamin K in our gut
it's dominated predominantly by
anaerobic bacteria and the phyla that
I've listed here and is very diverse in
normal healthy persons to help prevent
both local and systemic inflammation and
optimize immune function so it's very
important to have a symbiotic microbiome
we've learned this is critical not only
just for normal immune function but
prevention of overgrowth of pathogenic
bacteria prevention and trophic growth
of the GI tract to prevent breakdown of
the GI tract and now increasingly it's
become apparent that the success of
immunotherapy and cancer is critically
tied up with the influence of the
microbiome on our immune system this is
a recent review article which goes over
the many diverse ways that the gut
microbiome influences cd8 function
natural killer cell function dendritic
antigen presentation and other arms of
the immune system
hence again we want now in the Modern
Age of therapy to minimize primary
prophylaxis to optimize secondary
prophylaxis by early detection of
pathogenic bacteria and not overdoing
antibiotics at any course during the
therapy for the patient to optimize
their own immune system's ability to
control their cancer and to optimize
cellular therapy and immunotherapy going
forward
so some things about what we have
witnessed in terms of the t2 T2 system
for our own population we I have listed
here some patients who had a positive T2
result and a negative culture
subsequently which is not an uncommon
result in our population
many of the results that we've been
seeing are for pseudomonas organisms and
one had a coincidence infection with
klebsiella as well
uh
uh oh somebody's telling me they've lost
connection with me uh
can people hear me uh somebody can tell
me whether I'm still coming through I
think I'm still coming through
in any event I am on slide 34 yes good
um so pseudomonas is a big issue why is
it such a big issue in our population
well
again we're trying to avoid as much as
possible Draconian early antibiotics in
our population and pseudomonas is a very
common gut commensal and is often
therefore at low levels in GI tracts of
our patients when they have their first
fever and hence that's a very important
thing for us to be able to detect
quickly so the Advent of T2 results
early before culture has allowed us to
again intervene early with regard to
antibiotic support for what could be a
life-threatening infection if let go for
long enough to have the culture turn
positive over what often is 12 to 24
hours for that to occur
two out of ten had candida peroxillosis
one also had coincidentally with it
pseudomonas both patients were on
anaerobic coverage interestingly at the
time of this again to emphasize the
importance of anaerobes in terms of
trophic messages to the GI tract and the
immune system
and how important that is for the
control of infections in our population
one had enterococcus vcm one head staph
aureus and all of these positive culture
positive T2 results with negative
cultures happened relatively early in
the course of our patients we did trait
based on these T2 results would there
have been a difference in mortality or
the overall response for patients who
had been treated later based on cultural
results alone based on Modern therapy
now where we're de-emphasizing early
antibiotics it's hard to say but
certainly we're very happy to see this
early recognition and ability to treat
ahead of culture results
uh there were uh rarely a T2 negative
but culture positive result that
happened in our population we had one
patient with an E coli on culture that
didn't get found with the t2 bacterial
panel there was also strepmitus found in
the same patient which seemed to imply
that this was probably some sort of
bacterial translocation
this was a patient
um this was a patient who had a
complicated course with GI graft versus
host disease on and on multiple
antibiotics at the time that this study
was done which may have complicated the
interpretation
and finally as Dr Snyder had mentioned
during his presentation there are
certainly organisms that happen on the
t2 on on culture which are not currently
represented in the t2 panel which
include those listed here
um those some of which are important and
we'd like to see certainly included in
future versions of this there will
always be a relative balance of risk and
benefit for which of these organisms
plays a greater role in early morbidity
and mortality that need to be decided
quickly with regard to antibiotics
versus those that can comfortably be
found on culture and not make an overall
clinical difference for patients but
that will come from further
understanding and research I believe on
this system
so the benefits of the t2 system
we've certainly seen a rapid ability to
treatment focused organisms and prevent
broad spectrum sometimes more broader
Spectrum antibiotics which helps us to
preserve the relative uh health of the
microbiome which is again as I've
mentioned a critical issue in the age of
modern immunotherapy so it helps us to
prevent over treatment and it is a
relatively easy method of testing
notwithstanding as Dr Snyder has brought
up the need for peripheral culture and
the need for adequate blood supply for
the test
open questions with regards to the t2
system is how much we should trust
negative results in terms of making
decisions about earlier broad spectrum
antibiotics
polymicrobial interference with results
and it's very helpful for a more
targeted approach when positive early
and with that I will finish my section
of the presentation and ask for any
questions again I'd like to thank the
organizers and certainly our partner Dr
Snyder who helped to make this system
possible at our Institution
thank you so much Dr Snyder and Dr
Emmons for your informative presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar if you have a question
you'd like to ask please do so now just
click on the ask a question box located
on the far left of your screen and we'll
answer as many of your questions as we
have time for
now let's get started
our first question
um does T2 result provide additional
practical value to determine or change
type of treatment because the patient is
still treated with a broad spectrum of
antibiotics
uh I'll I'll take that first I guess in
that um you know we are trying to be
more tailored again in our approach so
we do certainly have a very great
respect for Graham negative organisms
for neutropenic patients who are
immunocompromised early and so drugs
like cefepime uh often uh you know
assume a mantle early but we try to
avoid drugs like zosin or others that
are very uh toxic to both the anaerobic
as well as gram-negative organisms in
the GI tract especially
in the future we'd love to be able to be
even more tailored than that such that
we can avoid again as much
synergistic toxicity to other bacteria
and preserve as much of the microbiome
as possible going forward as we're now
learning how critical it is not just for
again the overall gut health but the
effectiveness of immunotherapy
thank you for that
question do you have one recommendation
on how to convince the hospitals see
suit that this was a valuable diagnostic
investment and second part also have you
been asked to periodically or
retrospectively Justify the value of the
test
I'm anticipating that last question to
be coming forward
I've learned that with a couple other of
our Technologies we have to be prepared
to respond to those questions regarding
your first questions uh I think the best
answer I can give you is show them the
data indicate what it means
and the value added that this technology
will have to patient management
and that combined with the support of
the service such as Dr Emma's and his
group to bring this forward so be
prepared to deal with the administrators
and more for the financial aspect but
the clinical value added that this
technology will have but there will be a
time when we're going to have to prove
that this technology or their investment
did end up in a positive manner as
opposed to under utilization we learned
that with another technology which
prompted us to start a a rather intense
educational process of the medical staff
and I think that's beginning to pay off
so it's a combination of the finances
but from my our perspective active the
clinical impact and the support of the
providers
great thank you another question for you
what other patient populations is this
testing used for and how does it differ
well the emergency medicine patients as
I indicated the Intensive Care patients
infectious disease can order the test
because they get many consults
uh uh for any physician other than on
those Services if they want the test uh
are encouraged to get an ID consult for
approval purposes
but right now it's restricted to those
areas that we've listed in our
discussion intensive care units
emergency medicine oncology and of
course the transplant programs
thank you
our next question for Dr Emmons can you
talk a little more about the patients
with polymicrobial infections where the
infections identified with the same T2
panel or a different draw times over the
course of the patient's stay
so in the ones that I mentioned uh they
were with the same culture and T2 panel
so there were certainly other cases that
I haven't talked about in which there
were evolutions of other bacterial
infections that happened over time in
these patients because again many of
these patients are in the hospital for
weeks with their various forms of
immunotherapy and things can change over
time
again this is to emphasize how
critically important it is to try to
preserve the gut health and the
microbiome in these patients as well as
possible to help avoid the evolution of
worsening relative immune system
problems and resistance in organisms
that develop over time so again
tailoring responses by early
understanding of what organism is
playing the greatest role is the
solution to the problem in the long run
and so greater use of systems like this
will I think help us to get there
thank you
um another question for you what steps
or data did your team need in order to
build clinical confidence in the t2 test
results
well we just needed to use it and see
how it compared to the gold standard of
culture as far as the way our team has
been seeing and adopting this over time
the thing that I guess we're still a
little
um less comfortable with is the question
of how to really interpret negative
results how much we can trust the
absence of serious bacterial infections
that require broader Spectrum
antibiotics when the t2 comes back
negative within that early period before
cultures are available so that's
something that I think it will take time
and familiarity but we'd love to see
greater results
from other groups about that as well
thank you we have time for just a few
more questions
um back to you Dr Snyder is this work
discussed as part of antimicrobial
stewardship committee or other clinical
committees
well the antimicrobial stewardship
committee has obviously is one of our
partners and uh they have accepted T2
and we're getting ready to do a study uh
with Pharmacy on the impact that it has
on and a microbial use so that has yet
to be completed but once again they have
been very supportive of what we're doing
when we're instrumental in their letter
writing to prompt the administration to
endorse this but I have to once again
mention that Dr Emmons and his group
were really the ones that put it over
the top
thank you I'll end with um one more
question here
is how are the results reported from the
laboratory to the clinical teams
well two ways the standard way is the
electronic but we call those results as
well
and pharmacy now has a visibility on our
reports so they know although we don't
call them yet but they know almost as
immediately after we call the unit or
the provider and in reality we we call
the unit
and we inform them of what has been
detected and of course with that you
know it's you record that as for
accountability purposes who did you talk
to have them repeat it and it'll show up
in the electronic report uh within
minutes after we make the call
great thank you again so much both Dr
Snyder and Dr Emmons for your time today
and your important research we'd also
like to thank lab roots and our sponsor
T2 biosystems for underwriting today's
educational webcasts before we go I'd
like to thank the audience for joining
us today and for their interesting
questions any questions we did not have
time for today and those submitted
during the on-demand period will be
addressed by the speaker
um speakers via the contact information
you provided at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand and
libraries will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with any one of
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time take
care everyone goodbye
thank you